my name is irina and i am ukrainian but  i've been living in belgium for 20 years  yesterday a family of  from odessa has arrived and they're with  us now so we're here now with my mom and  and this family to  to try to register them and see how  things will go further  but as you see already here how many  volunteers are helping i think it's not  only organizations but just people  passing by who would go buy  breakfast or  tea or coffee and help people and  the solidarity is enormous it's really  enormous and i think  i think it is because people  feel how close it is  it's happening just next door i mean  kiev is two hours flying  the the number of  help offers i have been receiving is  just unbelievable from all sides from  people i know i don't know i slightly  know face group groups  also in poland and romania et cetera  it's just unbelievable so we're really  really grateful for this  you